hi guys I hope you guys enjoy the season
two marathon of eating your feet make
sure to come back on Saturday November
16th for season three premiere okay so
here we are
season two eating your feet season two
season two I'm Andrew I'm Nikki and this
is Patrick so today our dear dear
friends Adam and Annie challenged us to
make mochi based on a viral video we
found on YouTube dude it so this video
comes from a channel called only in
Japan this guy Jon dog makes it this is
a street food shop in Japan they've got
two guys
oh there's swinging swinging mallets I
don't feel like a bowl looking thing so
this is the process of taking rice to
mochi which is this glutinous rice
substance we can't do that that was
really heavy he looked like he was
really like yeah so we're gonna bring on
our culinary expert and good friend yeah
hey Rhea come on down we're making mochi
yay what do you think it's fun yeah I
used to do it when I was in elementary
school
oh wow I asked my mom to get a photo
I've never had mochi so I'm very excited
Wow in addition to the special equipment
we also needed special rice which we
bought in advance because it needs to be
soaked overnight but what we also bought
is some mochi to eat right now oh the
texture is amazing the outside green
stuff is the mochi inside is red bean
paste and then it's covered in soybean
flour so the texture is very gelatinous
almost like very soft gummy bears so
this way of making mochi requires those
special equipment things there it's a
machine that makes mochi these things
I'll try to show it this organization
called Kizuna they actually have this
equipment because they do mochi making
classes so they're gonna lend it to us
off to the j ACCC so to make mochi we
are required to find some special
equipment and you have that special
equipment hi who are you and why do you
have this my name is Kent Mata May and I
work here at the Japanese American
culture and community center so right
now we're here in the james irvine
japanese garden in little tokyo and
we're going to be borrowing q zena's
machi suki equipment and Kizer knows
mission is to educate engage and empower
the next generation of Japanese and
Japanese American youth so in order to
make the mochi the traditional way
you're gonna need a few items one year
need a steamer to steam the mochi
gourmet rice and you're going to put it
in the suit and then once it's in there
you're gonna take the kena and you're
going to start breaking down the rice
from its green structure to basically a
paste
I'm gonna take my left hand and make a
fist on top and we're gonna push down
into the blue foo like this how long
does the counting process typically take
depends how much effort you put into it
okay so for your team for example we can
we can get through one one she may be
ten to ten minutes
oh yeah do you think we can do this yeah
you folks are gonna be great Wow I got
the Kent seal of approval there do you
know the number of people who die every
year
it's been reduced when eating the mochi
I would say be very careful to chew it
very well
people who eat mochi I'm tendency to
choke on it and some people even die
eating it making yes well thank you for
giving us a little lesson of course I
think it's time for us to give it a go
look be careful thank you look like Paul
Bunyan alright ok so to make mochi you
start with rice and we have to get a
particular kind of rice that is meant
for mochi making which is a sweet mochi
rice it's superior short grain sweet
rice and now we need to cook it tent
recommended 1 cup rice to one and a
quarter cups water I think we should do
full yeah 4 cups of rice is 5 cups of
water
[Music]
now I'm measuring the water to rice
ratio beep it's not 60 minutes I could
just do double duty
[Music]
no light didn't come on is that bug
dinner Oh
Oh electronics so here we are we got it
clean it first I'll scrub it look like a
face yeah yeah no we put two eyes are
there it's important that mochi stays
hot while it's being made so we're using
warm water and hopes of warming up those
two altogether yeah this is incredible
all right guys good luck Oh should we
test the texture of it that's a lot of
water
that looks pretty gelatinous they say
it's probably all about and I feel like
even we pound it that's it it's just
gonna turn into mush we can try it but
my guts telling me maybe I don't know
guys I'm kind of into it yeah I hope
this work I mean I've never seen it so
[Music]
okay I have all the rice mail oh here it
comes
the malleus will help keep it hot
because we'll be dipping it in hot water
and the first thing we're doing is
squidging what's it feel like
oh it's so smushy now looks like mashed
potatoes how's it look really bad it
looks like two wooden horses are like
trying to like give each other I mean
it's sort of yeah okay yeah this isn't
gonna get gelatinous and bouncy I don't
think this is gonna get there it's
definitely pacing up but I get why we
would want to just actually start it the
right way from the start do you remember
this video he was clean
right like it's not coming go like this
it needs to be stickier
which means less water yeah I mean it
tastes like bland dry rice porridge so
yesterday we had some overnight soaked
rice that we put in a rice cooker but we
think that's wrong we think you only
soak if you're going to steam yeah what
is difference between cooking and
steaming the mechanism the mechanism so
my wok wife dough meets mom last borrow
steamer your work wife mother-in-law
yeah yeah yeah I love jet that looks
decided that we're going to steamed rice
instead of using the rice cooker I can
do that job I can do that job bottom
it's a pot so we feel weeds water and
lay boil we've got 8 cup soaked and do 4
cups per batch I got mugs for coffee
thank you I came at the wrong time and
then we spread these cheesecloth over
the steam arm so you just have to poke
the hole so the steam can escape all
right let's open this puppy on let it
steam for 30 to 40 minutes and we will
see if we truly could speak air steam
you want some I feel pretty good about
our steamer we had this classic method
but we weren't pairing it with the
classic method of stealing it we're
trying to go to high tech with that
robot
[Music]
what you want all right we're doing it
this looks good
oh yeah it doesn't look like porridge no
yeah that looks great this is yeah this
is different it's less sloshy and it's
motion
yeah it's way more encouraging Andrew
yeah let us know what you want to swap
get in there it's harder to press now
cuz it's oh yeah yesterday oh yeah look
at that weight getting there yeah that
looks pretty paced like imagine making
this in an apartment with your neighbors
down sit up good
it's more satisfying than the squishing
yeah Adams dying oh yeah oh gee Adams
doing the pounding that I like oh that
pulls pretty nicely yeah yeah the last
round of pound is with like one person
with their hands and they're flipping it
and slapping it while one person pounds
we're gonna do that very carefully no
you guys are too dangerous we beat the
of it now we're gonna cover it with some
warm towels to keep it hot so we're
gonna shape the mochi and this is much
conser rice flour
it's a little when you're shaping make
sure you're covered with your hand oh
it's flour cause it's really sticky this
was actually my first job when I was 14
[Music]
just for new year it feels really good
yeah I'm definitely thinking about like
choking and dying
pretty like a lot yeah I've been
thinking about that all night flower
hits the board yeah you stick to your
hands that suppose oh you got a cute
little yeah you did good so I think we
can eat it right now if you want you
yeah I want to eat it fresh oh yeah made
mochi yeah we did looking at the video
we have not made it green or filled it
with anything which should be our next
stage of the challenge I don't think we
can get this exact ingredient that makes
it green from the video the green is
coming from yomogi
it's a Japanese hard I've never seen
that anyway so maybe we can go to a
grocery store on to something else do
your monkey course we're gonna sample it
with soy sauce though it's popular way
to eat mochi Easley's soy sauce and
sugar a little bit sugar yeah and
seaweed looks great yeah yeah I'm
getting right in there oh yeah that's
really satisfying as a person who only
ever had ice cream mochi yes
flavor is a revelation
[Music]
we're back from the grocery store
sweet bean roasted soybean powder my
junk spittle yomogi is this gonna make
the cane a green you should be alright
we just have to be careful we're about
ready to make the next batch of mochi
all right first things first we got
steaming rice Bravo
that's pulse I think we just steamed it
the same way okay now we're gonna get
the beans ready to go can I tell you
that this is one of my favorite things
to do open cans yeah that's weird
alright so we're going to mash up some
of these beans to be more of a paste can
I ask a question about this bowl is it
used for any specific thing yeah we use
a full ground sesame it's so it's a
sesame baseball are you getting it - Oh
something else - yeah can you guys take
that over there create come here okay I
want that was my part doing our mochi
dance Junor mochi stance who are our
first mushers you want to be the first
mushers yeah so we got to put it in and
fold it through this journey I felt a
real team a ship with you guys I think
we could pound it for like 10% more get
it a smoother consistency
what must look like a sulfide yeah that
looks way greener Oh see this is
synchronicity this is what sting was
talking about yes that looks great very
slimy looking oh hell yeah every a you
know it really is starting to look a lot
like the video yeah get in there Pat you
got a pal ha ha you know making my
sounds really helps it does I think it's
bad right we're moving on to the next
phase of slapping pal
[Laughter]
give us the final slap
oh my god so you're going to take a look
portion all right I'm going in the Sui
Dean oh yeah that's you guys are doing a
good job yeah are you doing Oh bingo
Bongo I got it it's just my champion
success
we made mochi we really did we have a
green mochi is flavored with matcha
filled with red bean paste and covered
in a soybean powder the signs of
learning as well the red bean really
works so well I'm not real for funding
hi-yah
tickle show wise it's better than that
first try a lot smoother after we
switched to the steamer all the methods
that we did were as it would have been
done way back in history if you couldn't
opportunity to do this with bikini and
those Sue and a bunch of people do it
it's awesome maybe should invite a bunch
of her friends see these yeah it's a
good texture yeah this whole process was
made possible because of Kent and Kizuna
and the Japanese American cultural and
community center big thanks to them and
hit homies mom and he told me
okay so here we are eating your feed
where I've been challenged by Adam the
person behind the camera to mate and
pulled the noodles something I've never
made before in the offseason I said and
hey Adam
wouldn't be cool and make these noodles
completely forgot about it then he
brought it back on me and I was like
that looks so hard I regret ever saying
handful noodles we're going to do this
one made by this guy Peter song from
kung-fu kitchen in New York City it's
kind of like spinning together like if
you ever have we're on a swing set as a
kid and like wrapped it up and you sit
on it and spin around a lot until you
get close to throwing up like once it's
been needed he's just like watch the
noodle is pulled and then doubled over
and pulled again until he has noodle
sized noodles this is like the closest
that cooking gets to magic for me it's a
very simple dough it looks like flour
water he's using a bread flour with a
higher gluten content I think that's
gonna be important to talk through my
game plan
I have chef extraordinaire we a that a
good set up Adam hey hey REE a is a
tasty producer always helps us when
we're messing up with stuff so today I'm
doing the hand-pulled noodles what do
you think about that you don't need to
must I write you that's true too you
just have to make it happen I just need
some noodles in a bowl by the end of
tomorrow mm-hmm okay I'll let you know
if I need any help
bye hi okay so I did some measuring and
I've got 900 grams of flour
aka approximately 2 pounds I measured it
that way then Adam made me convert
science 20 grams of salt 450 grams of
water we begin now
[Music]
I'm gonna make a well this reminds me of
my cat because his name is Wellington
it's currently trying his hardest not to
look as doesn't seem like it's gonna be
enough water to be honest I mean I guess
when you think about it the flower is
like not just white dust but it started
out as hundreds of acres of plants and I
feel like I need more water I know what
you're feeling right now which is when
you see someone struggling with
something
it's like watching somebody open a jar
that's what this whole show is I think
it's time to let this rest so this dough
already feels a lot smoother do I need
uh some flour on this surface do I need
a flour on this surface
I shouldn't have added that flour
everything I'm reading says that you're
having a hard time with the elasticity
of the dough just needs to rest longer
you don't really see it in the reference
video when they do the cut and it comes
back with this shiny log of dough it's
because of the oil okay I think I'm
gonna try to the old snake test on this
thing what am i doing I think this
slapping is because the dough is it just
wants to return to its original shape oh
I broke it instead of giving up on this
dough I think I'm just going to add
water to it why did you let me do this
this is a bad idea
wretched it again am-scray yeah so
mistakes were made we found a very
useful Cook's Illustrated article it
turns out I did pretty much every ratio
incorrectly it also seems to be that
working with exclusively bread flour
you'll get the best result but it will
be harder to work with I feel good this
is like the stuff I should have done
before the first time so we have 900
grams flour seven grams salt 540 grams
of water for me a little well that one I
did good come back your water okay water
what are you doing why are you thinking
when you're kneading I think
doing this right I feel like maybe you
should wash your hands okay but like
your hands are like crust crust cross
crusty rusty
oh yeah you're so much better at this it
looks very smooth ER now think it was we
needed more water okay I think it's time
to let that rest so I'm gonna put that
in there so we've made four batches of
dough with different combinations of
Laur salt after it's had a really long
time to rest it should be really good to
go
tomorrow it's business time so yesterday
we prepared at four batches of dough
we're gonna go with the first one I made
it's quite cold I hope that doesn't
screw me over
oh okay
it's not uh-uh-uh-uh this feels like ABC
gum guys know that one already been
chewed I'm getting a couple nods from
around the room it looks like a little
slug room I think I need to let it rest
laurier
i thoughtyou coffee for everyone this
was actually completely on you just
leaving your like it it's really good
yeah okay we've let this dough log rest
I'm gonna gently stretch this out all
right when I double it over and see how
how this goes it's gotten so tight I
can't make a noodle from this it just
wants to break it reaches a tearing
point pretty easily so this one's
exactly the same as the last one but
with a different salt you do that much
stretching and then it's like we're
really just burning through our deck
here though AP & bread flour mixture
it's now genuinely at room temp and look
at this well it's pretty good
let me portion off a little bit and see
how far I can get with this come over
here and try this dough fight
[Music]
oh you're out it's the new thing you
know how chokers came back into style
this is a doaker this feels like Britney
Spears was the video toxic yep no it
just doesn't have the elasticity that I
think is required for this kind of
noodle we are in California one of the
driest periods we've ever had here all
of our recipes suggest that if it's
drier you're gonna need more water how
much more water I don't know I'm gonna
do 400 grams of water we just got to get
to a point where we're making noodles as
I thought my kneading days were behind
me at what point do I determine that
this is entirely too wet can I just pull
this into noodles right now I think I
need to add a little bit more flour to
this come on a little more
I need more flour
I called bolt on everybody's recipe that
ever published a thing about noodles he
was trying to keep the noodles for
themselves
I get it I would do it too I'm gonna
burn this tape when I successfully make
noodles okay having seen how these
videos get made I want to say cue the
heroic music now
okay okay okay okay I'm gonna cut off a
little section like this okay and then
I'm going to fold this back up oh I
worked so hard meeting that well I
reached the tearing point okay let's try
another recipe okay
we found this recipe utilizing a stand
mixer from this guy chef Thomas Johnson
let's just follow his recipe exactly see
if it works
cake flour all-purpose flour salt and
baking soda
whew okay boil water let's whack it up
going to speed for this is Brown that
will we yeah yeah that's completely the
wrong kind of flour
maybe if I added more water to this I
wouldn't work exactly too much water
so this was a failed attempt yeah that's
a wrap on day two this is gonna require
some further research so far for this
video we've been referencing recipes
that utilize high-gluten flour to
achieve a very pulley dough I found this
guy's website Luke Rui Mars there's like
nothing on it but this recipe but he
said views low-gluten flour and an
alkaline solution to help make a
suitably stretchy dough so I have
approximately 150 grams of cake flour
going into 25 grams of all-purpose flour
2 grams of salt and 1 gram of baking
soda huh
Oh to the wrong that's our 8 and 110
grams of water turn it into a squishy
paste
whereas we in the industry like to call
it dough and the oil at this point sure
why not it's quite wet and sticky very
nearly too sticky to work with the dough
should no longer bounce back but you can
see like when I put my fingers into it
it kind of holds its shape which is what
I ultimately want it to do but I'm gonna
give it a quick little pull test ready
for this it's still pretty brittle right
here and it definitely feels way
different than any previous batch oh the
dough is getting good oh yeah yeah
oh yay welcome how's it going
I've seen better days I'm using cake
flour for the first time yeah and I
needed this for like maybe 40 minutes 40
minutes by huh
yeah Wow I just don't have a delicate
enough touch to do it yet I need to
correct it really like delicate touch
boom boom
so you think cake flour i'ts to answer
this dough feels much nicer to work with
in any dough he had previously I feel
like you should have made it a little
longer that's a noodle Rea just leave
that there and then let's work on some
other noodles so much mage I don't know
oh hell yeah baby hey there's one noodle
okay that's not a big deal okay I have
one super fat one here this isn't
working
okay I give up on that okay so that's
pretty much the end of day three and I
think I'm at the part where I need to
really figure out how to pull them
evenly so tomorrow same dough recipe
working on the pulling hopefully we'll
have a bowl of noodles by the end of the
day so I needed it for about 40 to 50
minutes and now when I touch it it don't
bounce back okay ready here we go mmm
that's one thick noodle here's to
thinner noodles I mean that's like more
or less without those breaks that's
basically it that's noodles
that's noodles okay there's a little bit
of nibbles right there if I are good at
this you would just be able to make a
portion of noodles out of one pull but I
cannot do it evenly enough I think it
would take years of practice to get that
good so instead I'm just making like
four noodles at a time
we're ready to do the final plating of
these noodles I've got some salted water
boiling my noodles are slumbering under
here
I've got herbs she garnished the bowl
with hello ei how did it go not great
but at least the dough worked I have
some noodles here but I did that with my
hands no not a machine noodles are
cooking beef broth did you see that all
this is handmade Rea don't worry about
the broad if you'd like to see a broad
video we have a comment I'm straining my
noodles look at that
that's not tonne of noodles I just made
who hide this thick one huh I'm not
hiding my shame thick noodle goes back
in watch out we a dangerous I run a
tight ship over here in Andrews noodle
world yeah that's looking good cilantro
more cilantro onions some of these are
quite thick and how about for a splash
of color boom little chili oil good it's
a bowl noodles you did it sort of you
can see they're very uneven that's
easily the hardest part it's magic what
they do are you happy yes because it's
over yeah really it's very rigid Adam
you want to try some
good that's really tasty yeah yeah chili
oil this was the longest episode yet so
little was accomplished but you know
high respect oh yeah oh that must are
very much yeah
this has been eating the hand-pulled
noodles out of my feed oh yes okay so
here we are eating your feed the show
where people like me get challenged to
try and recreate viral food recipes my
friend Adam it's challenging me today to
make Japanese fluffy pancakes not a lot
of steps but it's going to require some
skill it's the perfect level for my
level of cooking which is amateur at
best but I'm optimistic hand mixer on
the egg whites getting it to the nice
stiff fluff there okay so now they're
adding the pancake mix into the three
and a half inch molds so they put the
lid on it rises 10 minutes now the flip
is going to be very difficult that is
pancake perfection right there I love
pancakes it's straight up so to help me
today is our food expert 3a okay thank
you for coming are you making today
fluffy Japanese pancakes okay yeah have
you eaten Japanese okay no so egg whites
it's the most important part of this
fluffy pancake if you over mix it become
very crumbly it's not that difficult a
scare sure anything you like
thank you right hi okay in here we have
our molds imagine that I mean everything
like living in Looney tune land where
tanks are this tall and fluffy so right
now we're going to take 2 egg yolks
quarter cup of sugar the people in other
countries get stressed out when they
watch us cooking just because I wish we
were saying it in the metric system it's
about time we switch huh half cup of
milk every last drop 3/4 cup of pancake
mix looks like 3/4 what you think guys
at home what's going in all right
whisking together you have that now
we're going to add our four egg whites
here's two okay that's three
all right for plugging our hand mixer
okay we're in no that is a great
question Adam I've never hand mixed
she's not gonna overthink it just gonna
go for it so that's what that button
does okay things are in also may just
need to be unlocked no okay we know what
that button does in hmm daddy's got a
beat it by hand I mean that's impossible
right I don't want to do that at all
okay new mixer okay what the f
I think we just have a bad power source
all right so we have a bad plug let's go
do the noise we're going all the way in
six by the way the volume is increasing
I'd say we're tripled maybe quadruple
the original volume close not Stan its
same the peak is staying okay let's see
if the tasty video see how peak that
that good no yeah this is it I think I
might have overdone it we're gonna get
in there but just slightly we want these
to mix together but we don't want to
lose the whip I think it's too crumbly
maybe not though it's not that far off
let's go for it let's get our Heat going
we're gonna put this on the lowest heat
one
all right both are in we greased up our
molds you know three quarters of the way
in okay let's cover it okay
pulling it off try and separate Jesus
disaster sorry folks
yeah okay well this is a failure it's a
miserable failure my god what is
happening here Patrick I don't think the
flame was high enough although it rose
so what the hell is that mean I don't
know it smells fantastic though so first
attempt didn't work what do we learn
flame will be a little bit higher and
maybe try them one at a time I don't
know second attempt we're gonna use what
was left in the batter put the lid on I
was using a fish spatula last time
because that's what they used in the
video but now I'm gonna use this one
because I can probably hook it in a lot
better bubbling up at the top looking
very similar to what we were doing
before it's making all types of cracking
noises stop doing that if I was someone
else if I was really be doing what you
need to do but for me two minutes we're
getting hot look how high that is I've
never cooked a pancake on one side for
ten minutes all right smells delicious
[Music]
well he burnt the bottom of that one we
knew that so we need you just the heat
can't figure out that I would have
flipped it off these tongs aren't it
these knees can't do it i greased up
then so I do I need to grease it win one
oh yeah that pancake II clogged your
windpipe this is fluffy they weren't
lying is everything you wanted on the
inside definitely more edgy but and try
it it's pretty good yeah not bad with
syrup butter the whole thing
uh-oh how's it going what is the best
way to flip it I think they say it's not
a good one another good let me get done
good one okay
dad's Hans these aren't tasty tongs that
was the problem you know I'm ready to
sell out so hard but no one will give me
a shot at selling out
I would sell out for a surprisingly low
amount 2019 I'm gonna be a micro
influencer
why did I want to sell out okay because
I was saying how these aren't any good
uh-huh and I would love to do it an
advertisement for a really good brand Oh
like pasty yes only at Walmart you see
how good she is it I will do that oh god
that was so easy oh you can feel the
silicon
oh my all right well that answer that
mix them up yeah that's stiff go okay
that looks decent
let's grease the molds okay that looks
about 3/4 cover it up ten minutes eight
minutes we're seeing some bubbling on
top normally talk a little powdered
sugar is fantastic five minutes
oh my spatula all right to it off
oh it's guys all right everyone relax
okay get it low get it low god I hate
the way this is shaking I hate the way
the sticking yeah that looks good that
Brown really was right about the a
temperature it overflowed like crazy my
goodness Oh put this back on can't get
ahead of yourself when cooking fat I
mean how many times are you happy well
the tongs worked so that's good one
minute oh my god everyone's square
plates where the thing the embarrassing
to have been you're home now
yeah yeah oh my god do we think
I mean it's brown it's not light brown
but it's brown
oh all right so the presentation of this
plate not great so now that I've gotten
this far I'm going to try and make two
at the same time and see if I can stack
them up and then I'll have some friends
over to try it out so lots of times
we're going to try and make two and
instead of using vegetable oil to grease
up the molds we're going to use spray
canola oil hopefully they'll make it
slide out a little bit better okay - got
it better here okay just a little bit
more ten minutes four minutes
yeah it's rising two minutes matter of
seconds
oh man look how much they've risen to 49
flippin come on man you can do it you
can do it bro oh yeah bear oh yeah hell
yeah why not me one two
23 skidoo here we go oh my god a laptop
just fell then everything's crazy right
now we're flipping anyways made 800 God
why God no all right screw it this is
the last one all right here we go mother
who cares honestly who cares whatever
foot it back on I'll cut around it this
sucks
this really sucks cooking is fun right
Adam is trying to cheer me up behind the
camera
maybe these are salvageable who knows
well see how my mood is in four minutes
so let's check back in then alright
let's take them out they look way better
you know my kids are getting these and
I'm liking them that's how this goes in
my house you want to cry about it well
guess it's not even fluffy Japanese
pancakes I'm gonna try and cut these out
using a method that Adam came up with by
pushing down hopefully that eliminates
everything there and I can just flick it
up Oh
oh my god Adam you little whiz kid you
freakin figured it out okay there's one
whoa
and all the sins are forgiven of that
terrible flip - oh right
oh my god guys breakfast is served
Wow comment below what you think cuz to
me not bad
I've cut the butter now that's just the
bun oh no we'll flip it over yep we'll
flip it over hell yeah dude we'll flip
it over here it is guys wow that's
that's very jiggly yeah man that's not
it
I'm not gonna slap it you slap it oh wow
it's bottles dirty yeah how many times
did you try this is the fourth time oh
yeah
it's good oh yeah right there I like no
no wow look like a kink oh just jumping
in again there again there anna has
anyone had a restaurant version of this
before me how does this compare I think
yeah you know that right wow thank you
okay you're gonna whip this out and like
the weekends now I know yeah I'm into it
I say the flip was the most challenging
part
I'm sure there's like an algorithm to
figuring out the right speed versus
velocity of rotation etc etc give me
10,000 hours check back in will see
where I'm at
well I'm proud of myself it's been
another episode of eating your feed I'm
proud of you too hey thanks okay so here
we are eating your feet my name is Nikki
today my friend andrew has challenged me
to recreate a very expensive beef
sandwich that he tried while he was in
Japan shooting worth that everyone in
this room has had the sandwich except
for me here's the video this is at a
restaurant in Tokyo called Wagyu mafia
cutlet sandwich so andrew tried the Kobe
beef
Chateaubriand penwick and Wow that piece
of meat is luxurious it's spotted like a
leopard with fat dredge it in an egg
wash and panco just deep-fry it like
fried chicken
and they have these beautiful pieces of
fluffy white bread oh this is my kind of
sandwich she cut the crusts off 20,000
yen yaoi is Kobe beef the same as Wagyu
beef I googled Kobe beef and the thing
that is up for sale is Wagyu beef Wagyu
beef is any of the four Japanese breeds
of cattle there's also one called send
abuse I thought it said Sandra beef and
I really like the idea of there being a
buccal syndrome it's and uh I'll buy a
piece of beef and call it Sandra you
should also buy some less expensive meat
and plate this with that first maybe
some test beef yeah so as always to help
our very good friend and chef
extraordinaire Rhea is here are you good
I'm making a Japanese sandwich today
yeah I remember this place is it good
that's good so wag you means Japanese
beef and then this was a Kobe
Chateaubriand is that a
cut of beef yeah yes am I gonna be able
to find that here you may able to lie
beside me in a restaurant saying like
all the beef hmm and then it's not just
like a regular kutsu sauce we can buy us
sauce cold
tonkatsu sauce yes and then it's bread I
would like to eat just taking people's
orders now that's a little bit lighter
texture fluffier yeah fluffier and so
the inside is not cooked all the way
through higher temperature and shorter
cook time exactly good luck thanks bye
so we need to get cheap beef fancy beef
tonkatsu sauce bread crumbs white bread
preferably Japanese boyfriend I think I
can do this and I think it's gonna be a
really delicious day we got the B it's
not much the guy who sold it to us said
this is its superior piece of meat
second only to Japanese Mikey all right
stuff hey we got two square loaves cheap
beef expensive beef we have our cuts of
sauce and we've got some panko in here
we also have some treat okay so we got
this bread from a Korean supermarket in
Koreatown but they also had a bakery so
we got something hot dog buns I got this
pink baguette oh yeah I do
Everywhere's looks like you're eating
patrick stars a hand good luck thank you
I guess we get cooking so this process
requires deep frying things which
naturally makes me a little bit nervous
but I've got my pot of oil and we want
that too
oh I don't know anything about
temperature or time difference Amy she
said high temperature before a short
amount of time well I mean it has to get
hot your my thermometer I'm not like -
oh my god
okay well safety first that's heating up
so from what I can tell the beef is not
like seasoned in any way ingredients
wise is pretty basic so the fantasy wag
you that we got today is not Kobe Wagyu
but it's Australian Wagyu from Blackmore
farm and it is from a Chateaubriand cut
it is about an inch and a half thick and
it's $40 I think this is like the
smallest most expensive piece of beef
I've ever cooked we're not gonna start
with that because if I mess it up we
only have one so we bought some backup
beef Black Angus tenderloins but they
seem to be the right size this is the
Black Angus that is like seven dollars
per tenderloin and this is the
Chateaubriand Wagyu which is 40
something dollars this one definitely
has better marbling but like still not
quite like in the video in Japan but it
was the best we could do right
it goes flour and then eggs I don't got
two eggs but I think that should be fun
should I put salt in the flour I don't
remember if they salted it I would
definitely a salt the outside after it's
done frying well anything stick if it
comes fresh out of the oil and it just
that's like the time to solve right
thing
oh that's a lot of pink oh and also on
the video they cook with chopsticks
that's what I'm gonna do I'm about to
deliver a beef baby the thermometer says
deep fry is near 375 which sounds about
right
here's our tenderloin fell into three
pieces because what did you give her
Bing $15 for two tenderloins I had Wagyu
beef for the first time this summer at a
fancy Japanese restaurant and I cried
all right well I'm gonna dip this an egg
panko mountains
yeah that's Philly a well covered piece
of beef should do this little buddy
it looks like an apostrophe that can be
my test test apiece singing Nikki's face
above the pot is very funny from over
here all right we're there we're going
in and starting a timer this is fun just
sitting over here washing your back seat
on the front seat good okay that's one
minute it's so brown and crispy all
right 1:30 salt oh it's definitely rare
might be a little too rare it's hard to
tell though cuz this size of this guy
was also really small let's try the big
one see what we can do maybe we can make
a sandwich out of that one I remember
their beef taking kind of a while to try
really maybe it's a lower temp and a
longer fry that's 2 minutes and 30
seconds all right let's test it with
like the end piece of this guy Wow such
puffy bread sauce on both pieces of
bread or just one maybe a light coating
on both mmm sauce and I think they cut
the crust off after the sandwich is a
something nice and now I cut it into
quarters looks great looks pretty good
pretty close right yeah let's give it a
go
Oh Henner there's not a ton of beef
flavor it's mostly just like soft
texture with crunchy texture I think you
can't go a little less two less fry
mm-hmm guys is a little overdone how the
floor may be a long minute and a half
wait when you take out the meat it's
still okay so I'll try it again with my
second piece of cheap meat figure out a
better cook time I'm hoping this will
just stay together when I fry it we're
gonna take it down to a minute and a
half
hopefully get a little bit more of a
rare inside and assemble another
sandwich cutting the bread at an angle
here because not a lot about me is very
straight so hopefully I can do a
straighter job well that's not a bad
slice okay minute 30
oh the piece didn't come off so Oh layer
of sauce at the Wagyu Sando place if
there's a little bit of meat that makes
it not a square it'll cut it a little
bit so that'll be more square like that
looks a lot better I think this cook
time was closer to what we should be
doing okay I think this is good you can
see the toasty bread the sauce the cuts
it adding and my friend Sean's here hi
Sean come on
I made a cheap beef katsu Sando
but you were just in Japan there was
just you and you are Japanese yep so you
were familiar with the concept of the
cut suits and oh yes please enjoy pretty
good yeah although the beef is like not
super cooked which is good and we ate
the expensive one you just pull the meat
away from the sandwich then you have to
cut it with your teeth right because
that has to do the fat content mmm the
fattier it is the more it like breaks
apart more easily okay well there are no
more cheap steaks to futz with it's
finally time to face my fears of this
very expensive piece of beef I think I'm
gonna slice my bread slices and have
them ready to go in the toaster it's
beef time to up the stakes if you will
injure Andrea we're gonna be here while
I make it calm in my palms are sweating
you're sweating I'm sweating here
yes Angela she's beautiful not perfectly
round she is should I dab yeah I was
talking about dabbing the meat and Adam
thought I was gonna like dab dab like a
12 year old boy it's got very nice
marbling
yeah it's soft it's very tender can I do
a deal so much to you
what's an idiot say okay what is
happening guys
okay here she goes by Sandra me a timer
yes Fred's toasting I'm very nervous
been a minute 30 oh nice color oh that
piece about funky that's okay you'll cut
that off
you're like a coach it's time for Sandra
she's big oh wow that's thick a mom and
dad behind me you can do it okay I ready
it's basically just toasted meat right
this is really really ridiculous okay
let's make it Wagyu beef I cried I
really don't know what's gonna happen
here
oh the juices are running
that's so decadent whether it tastes
like daughters marshmallow like a beef
mallow mmm this one has a beefiness that
the other tube didn't have feel like the
fat has a flavor of its own and this one
that is present in the others this one
the beef is the star I feel like in the
other pieces we were talking about the
bread and sauce on this one like the
beef just really really stands out yeah
that's crazy that's good Thank You Annie
I heard you were excited to try some
beef I was you're not in the rare beef
no I'll try anything we thought like we
all ate it and it was just bad food
really really good yeah someone's life
today we had a very expensive piece of
Wagyu Chateaubriand that was dredged in
flour eggs and panko and then deep-fried
until it was rare and then we had some
soft fluffy Japanese white bread covered
in a katsu sauce with the meat placed on
it cut into quarters I can't even
imagine what that restaurant is doing
with like high tier Japanese Kobe Wagyu
beef but I think with whatever a piece
of beef you can find if you want to do
this at home you totally can
I'd say definitely spring for the good
Asian bread get a good sauce you need a
delicious sandwich whoa I just smell
like beef
oh yes